this is the bismillah al hamdulillah
Salaam alaikum peace be with you I may
be your host and we are out of the Dean
shell studio this week and we're
visiting an old friend and for many of
you a new friend so we did a show way
back with Sanna Sanna who dr. mahamadu
was the anchor of that show and if
you're interested to see that show which
I'm sure you are to get to know who
sun'll is you go to the Dean show calm
and many of you now who are tuning in
for the first time you get to see sanaa
who was in better health back then he
has a condition called spinal muscular
atrophy and alhamdulillah we did the
show so many people can benefit from
seeing a young boy such as himself who's
in a wheelchair who cannot do many of
the things that young boys and girls can
do or for that young adults can do but
he's still very buoyant he's still very
cheerful he doesn't complain like many
of us always complaining complaining day
and night so we did that show so
inshallah God one of many other people
can reflect of the countless blessings
that the creator of the heavens and
earth has given us and many of us we
don't see these we don't reflect over
them and many of us we take our health
and we take many things for granted so
you got to see the show and now you get
to see son o who has caught pneumonia he
got sick so he's in the hospital we came
to visit him so many of the fans that
son o got from watching his last show we
wanted to bring you up to speed so you
can see Sano in the condition that he's
in and make dua for him no visiting the
sick is has so many great rewards in
Islam and also you know in these
situations when the person who's sick
and the people come to see him you know
not only are we praying for them to get
better but we're also taking a time to
reflect to reflect about our life
are we really working towards pleasing
our Creator before we meet our Creator
many of us are just wasting time so we
came here to the hospital so we can
benefit from this situation so we can
look into his life and see how blessed
many of us are but we take these
blessings for granted we take these
wonderful blessings for granted and I've
gotten spent a lot of time with son or
not once have I heard him complain and
may god almighty the Creator Allah
continue to bless him and continue to
you know have a special place for
prepared for him and Jenna in paradise
you know but for us to really get to
reflect about our lives to really get to
reflect are we taking time to get closer
to our crater before we meet our crater
are we taking time as you see son L
right here and the footage is that
you're seeing the footage that you
saying he might not have many of the
things that you might have but he has
that conviction in his heart he has that
faith in a certainty of his creator and
he takes a timeout and he reflects and
he calls upon his creator are you doing
that are you taking a timeout are you
reflecting about the purpose of life are
you reflecting on all the blessings that
the craters given you we'll be right
back so Michael my name is Salim Ahmed
image I will be the guest on the Dean
show telling you about my life and don't
get it go anywhere we'll be right back
but ii jus me know this is the things is
the danger
this is the thing you know this is the
thing is the theme this is the this is
the pain so as the last and final
messenger sent to mankind the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him he told us to
really reflect often about def reflect
upon the destroyer of pleasures many of
us are delighting in our lusts and our
passions were chasing this world we're
chasing that dollar we're chasing all
the material things we're working on our
physical physique and we're working on
our minds but the soul we're neglecting
it so before a situation comes where you
might end up in a hospital you might end
up with no legs you might end up with no
eyes you might end up in a situation
that you won't be able to even make a
prostration to your crater you won't
even be able to do the things that
you're doing now now is the time as you
see our young brother here God willing
this will help open up some some of the
hard hearts some of the hard hearts that
just have gone away that they've made
money their God they've made a woman
their God they've made a man their god
that's all they think about is the next
party or the next good time but as you
see if tomorrow you get hit by a truck
or a car or you fall from a fall tall
building or you get cancer or you get a
disease that you're not you're
terminally ill and now you you lose all
these wonderful benefits take advantage
of your health now and use it in the
proper way in the proper channels if
you're watching this show this week's
episode of the Dean show visiting sana
here in the hospital and if this is
affecting you in a positive way that
it's softening your heart that's what
it's meant to do and God willing we
don't want you to leave
to the next channel going to the next
thing that is on your mind after you
leave us here this evening or when
you're watching us during the day and
you just continue on being neglectful
neglectful of many of your
responsibilities if you're Muslim you
know that as Muslims we need to be
praying we need to be establishing that
direct connection with our career
minimum five times a day we need to stay
away from the things that are
displeasing to the God Almighty we need
to pray to Him alone and not his
creation we need to follow the Sunnah
the way of the last and final messenger
sent to mankind and stay away from
gambling and alcohol and drugs
promiscuity there's no dating in Islam
and many of the youth are caught up on
the facebooks caught up on the myspace
is caught up on many of these media
things that are out there and using them
in an unproductive way so if you see if
you're a young boy or young girl and you
have parents and you're disrespecting
your parents as can be you tomorrow it
can be you tomorrow that now your health
that now you might be playing soccer
baseball football and now you get hit
and you end up paralyzed or you end up
getting struck down and you're in the
hospital and it's almost flat lying now
is the time you're deaf the Deaf that
angel of death can come at any time
moloko mode he's there waiting so are
you prepared for that moment that moment
when your soul will be extracted from
your body are you ready to meet your
Creator when you're six feet under five
feet under in the ground and the dirt is
thrown over your body then it's too late
now is the time you see our brother so
now you see him in his situation pray
for him make dua for him but look at
your life
let us look at our lives are we are we
staying away from the things that our
Creator has told us to stay away from
and implementing all the beautiful
injunctions the beautiful things that he
wants us to do one that we worship none
but him that we don't worship a man or a
woman we don't worship the creation we
worship the god of jesus the god of
Moses the God of Abraham the one create
or have you even asked for guidance I
meet so many people and I asked them to
simple question have you ever asked the
create or to guide you if you need to
get to losing Louisiana or Miami or you
need to get down the block and you have
never been to a certain place you ask
for directions are you asking for
direction in life so mean so many people
are stumbling in the dark they're not
even reflecting about why they've been
created what the purpose of life is
now's your time and reflect if you're
turning into the show you got a purpose
and you got one chance to make it right
to make it happen start with asking and
reflecting and asking the one who
created Croatia to guide you ask the one
who all the messages of God including
Jesus Moses Abraham and the last and
final mission to prov Muhammad peace be
upon him you don't worship any of these
creatures of God they were teachers of
God and you call upon the One God not
through intermediaries you don't go
through anyone you go directly to God
because there is no sanction there is no
justification for us to pray to any
creation or go through an intermediary
these are all pagan ideas these are all
pagan inventions all pagan concoctions
that have crept up into the culture of
society all the messages of God they
came with the same message worship the
one unseen creator and pray and
establish a relationship with him alone
don't do things that will only ruin your
life and that's by not getting things
together before it's too late like
getting involved in drinking and
gambling and chasing your lusts and
desires day and night from one weekend
to the next weekend
what am I going to wear how am I going
to press this person this individual and
all the things that are being talked
about are things that really at the end
of the day they carry no value gossiping
backbiting you know if we implement the
way of life that the Creator wants us to
live it's all based on goodness it's all
based on that which will bring you peace
and happiness we'll be right back peace
be unto you welcome to the D show Ahmed
of your host and we got our brother in
humanity who I just came across you know
we're all brothers and Humanities did
you know that I kind of surprised you I
saw you walking and I got your attention
and when I say brothers in humanity that
means that we're actually brothers not
blood brothers but in humanity we're
brothers did you know that oh I got to
know that you learn something huh oh
yeah I my name is eddie what's your name
yeah my name is lon lon nice to meet you
an Emmy tid where are you from China
China have you ever heard I heard
there's like a hundred million Muslims
in China are mostly I'm in China yeah
okay yeah did you know that did you ever
meet a Muslim in China I mean oh um you
know do you know anything besides you
know you know the media you know the TV
and then you hear Muslim and then boom
big bomb exploding and you think oh the
Muslims coming I better hide did you did
you ever see this or think this no maybe
in ethanol not heavily in China in what
uh it's not happy in China right it's
not happy yeah i yeah so let me tell you
now have you ever considered the purpose
of life do you believe in a god ah not
yet not yet a creator like you see the
trees and you see the birds and you see
yourself how did the trees and the birds
and your Prentice see down in the ground
and the vegetation comes up did you ever
reflect that I came from a point in my
life where I didn't exist I came
to my mother's room I came out now your
big strong handsome man how did all
these happens did you ever reflect about
this think about it consider it yeah I
mean maybe sometime sometime because
this is something that Islam is calling
us to think about Islam means to some
submit you know you submit someone says
give them up giving might you say okay
here's my mind you surrender you know
you submit you surrender but it's
sincerely doing this out of your free
choice to the one who created all this
not to a man not to a man because man
eats goes to the bathroom not to a man
not to a woman even though should
woman's beautiful right man loves women
so not to a man not to a woman not to
money not to anything in the creation
but only the one who created the
creation does that make sense just God
if you have a cow in front of you're
looking at a cow a monkey a man or the
one who created everything wouldn't it
make sense to worship and submit to the
one who created everything Oh another
think of I before honey I quite amazing
it's amazing what we're saying what I'm
saying is it making sense yeah like one
plus one is two now if I said one plus
one is 53 would that make sense yeah
yeah maybe one pathway and chloride is
too yeah but if I said one plus one is
five does that make sense no no so look
make it simple one guy uh-huh that makes
sense just 11 Creator wanna huh Hulk
great oh-ho one God how do you saw God
in Chinese god the thought of it if God
for the cat cat that here katha dear God
carefully carefully yeah or maybe so
maybe what in Chinese yeah how you
saying Chinese so she'll send Cinzia
Cinzia yeah how you how you say how you
doing in Chinese doing what how are you
Neha Neha teach me something in Chinese
Oh what do you want to learn how are you
today uh teen handle yeah and I say good
good but the oh okay well thank you very
much at least now when you leave back
home you met a Muslim and I I'm a Muslim
and I believe in one God and doing good
and being good to Chinese being good to
Japanese being good with all of mankind
and we don't believe in hurting innocent
people and we're not crazy terrorists
and whatnot so at least we develop a
friendship today and then you learn to
to leave from here and think about
purpose of life why we're here I will
yeah I will okay I appreciate you
talking with us okay uh that's a lot of
kind of your ID yeah nettle me to you
here nice to meet you too thank you very
much thank you thank you guys thank you
guys why we implement this way of life
that the crater sent down through all
the messengers this is the way of life
they'll bring us peace contentment and
happiness throughout all the confusion
that's out there chaos people are on
drugs people are suicidal people don't
know where to go left or right or
straight they have no idea let's stop
right now if you're watching this and
just sincerely ask the one who created
you the one creator don't go through
anybody don't go through Mohammed or
Jesus or Moses pray to God alone
directly and ask the crater to guide you
and then be courageous enough when the
truth comes to you to be on it stopped
working worrying about what all the
other people going to say if everybody
if 999 people are going to the nightclub
you don't have to be that to make it a
thousand you don't have to make it even
you can be that one person who's on a
moral ground that many people today have
lost people's moral compasses off but
when you reflect on sun oh right here
and you look at his life this might be
you tomorrow you might be in even a
worse situation but now you have a
chance God Almighty he gives wealth and
he gives Dominion he gives God Almighty
gives wealth and he gives children to
whom He wills but
when he loves someone he gives them the
guidance so ask for the guidance and for
our young youth and even the males out
there females who all they're thinking
about all they're thinking about is
satisfying their lusts and desires know
that we really have one shot to get it
together and this is the time this is
the time right now after the show I want
you to be committed to action and that
action is to develop yourself to be the
best human being that you can be and you
can't do it on your own whims and
fancies you're going to have to follow a
game plan and that game plan is the
craters in the game plan it's not what
you or your own call your grandparents
made up a decade ago essentially going
now you just blindly following your your
your your forefathers know that way of
life that God Almighty is sent down as
simple as straight to the point worship
one God submit to him don't worship His
creation in the last and final message I
was sent to mankind as the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him his way his
son the same way if you live in during
the time of Jesus you would have to
follow his way you can bypass him but no
way ever that any of the messages of God
tell you to worship themselves or
worship anyone along side with the crate
or and then you're going to establish
the prayer five times a day minimum five
times a day and from there you're going
to stay away from everything you're
going to strive to better your life by
staying away from everything that's
bringing or couldn't possibly bring you
harm and the only way you're going to do
that do that is to seek knowledge to
spend time not watching all day MTV pit
my ride jersey Shore's these things I
have no benefit def and the day of
judgment the mercy of Allah these are
the things that finally made me realize
there is no time to deal
anymore I wanted to take Marshall harder
right there great the essence of
spirituality is to become more sincere
to Allah span without much play tennis
so it is very very scary but it brings
you back to reality there is a life
which is everlasting and you have to
make a conscious decision or which group
of people do you want to be off the
people are having over the people of
help oh so before we cut out take a good
look pray for our brothers so now and
really let us reflect upon our lives are
we complaining are we ungrateful and
thankful for all the wonderful blessings
of the crater has given us so many
blessings if you were trying to try to
enumerate the countless blessings that
have been given to us human beings you
could not but many of us are ungrateful
and unforgiveness in this life and we go
on life heedless we don't think about
the consequences there's a hellfire and
it's a very hot place we don't want to
end up there and there's a paradise
that's where we want to be and that's
eternal bliss and happiness we will all
die we will all leave this earth and
it's time for us to do righteous good
deeds and it has to be based on pure
monotheism not paganism pure monotheism
that means worshiping the unseen guide
who is the creator and not created he's
one and no more don't add anything to it
don't subtract from it he's truly
independent of all and we're all
dependent on him he doesn't rest he
doesn't sleep he doesn't have
grandchildren he doesn't have a father a
mother he doesn't have a daughter a son
no he's the creator and he doesn't need
anyone and we all need him he's the one
God that Jesus peace be upon him worship
Moses called us to worship the One God
Abraham did in the last and final
mission a problem i'm at peace be upon
him so let us reflect let us take this
moment as we see our young brother and
really reflect before def creeps up from
around the corner and then it's too late
and then it's done and then we're in the
grave and those people who are in the
grave they're not thinking about the
wealth that they left it behind they're
thinking about how they can come back
and do good now's your chance to do
good to be upon good before that angel
of death comes to take your soul our
soul solo continue to tune into the Dean
show every week we're here talking about
more serious issues talking about things
that will enlighten the minds if you let
it come in things that will only benefit
you things that can only bring you peace
and happiness if you turn to the owner
of peace that's the one create tour so
continue to tune into the Dean she'll
make do I'll for our brother son L and
we will see you next time same time same
Channel until then peace be unto you
sonam like
you